for much of the winter eric Salatin
makes his living from trapping fur today
he's hoping a new kind of trap will
bring him success up a box kind of bear
330s those traps different than most of
the traps i use in that it actually
breaks the neck of the animal and kills
it instantly whereas most of the traps I
use our leg holds and just catch the
animals foot trying to construct a box
here to put a 330 Conibear in something
I've never done I'm not that good of
carpenter but I don't think the animals
will notice okay I think my cubby set
box is going to work so the idea is the
bait is placed in the back of the cubby
the animal comes along he sees the bait
in the back he goes in he hits this
trigger mechanism snap it instantly
kills him and his burrow humane way to
harvest foxes or Wolverine so I think we
succeeded
okay now we're gonna go to Phase two
which is to actually test this and make
sure that the jaws flow freely inside
the cubby box I made safety is now off
that is a pot very powerful trap the 330
cotton bear here it's a large trap so
I'm a little bit leery about the Sun gun
here and if they don't want to be
putting my arm in there I'm pretty sure
it would actually break your arm that's
what happens Jesus Christ that's
powerful yes it works